we're in q1 you know what that means
first-quarter dear john ear for every
March I guess video games fiscal video
fiscal everyone likes talking about
things in terms of corporations and
money and stuff as we're to talk about
all the games that come in in q1 2016
what's coming in January for every March
traditionally kind of a class you know
super not dense but it's kind of a
little bit dense this year beep yeah a
lot of stuff but uh a lot of stuff was
delayed for just me yeah so yeah my one
day back from work and then rushing to
CES has sent me up horribly for the
coming weeks because there are a lot of
games coming out awesome i'm gonna run
through this list as a sort of just so
people kind of no housekeeping wise
what's coming out so get your pen and
paper if people still have that and
remind yourself of some other great
games coming out so today I gone homes
coming out in console that dragon cancer
is also at today review going on
gamespot real soon right Pete yep
awesome and gunnery fifteenth oxen free
later this week any all interested in
that I Mary's from playing it a bunch
and she seems super interested yeah I'm
uh I don't know if I'm totally
interested in okay I've heard some like
mixed things about it and time is so
precious right now but that said a lot
of people have plated are really
enjoying it so I mean maybe I'll give it
a shot if I have more time assignments
posed to be that long like five or six
rhythms yeah okay again that the sort of
thing you play over and over again right
a game that you probably only got one of
they once January 26 the witness finally
comes out John blows follow-up to 2007
sprite I want to say it's been a while
yeah those are separate yes a long long
time ago that's gonna be an interesting
woman should not all okay probably not
so much I mean it looks really cool um
and you never liked it's a lot of
puzzles there's like 650 or something
and like one of them's like I think John
blows like oh yeah I think one percent
of you guys are gonna get this poor
really Jesus add that same day Lego
Marvel's Avengers is coming at so maybe
you can play that instead at two days
after da January 28th rise of the Tomb
Raider finally comes out on pc i know
people be happy about that if every
fifth then XCOM 2 that's gonna be
exciting I know Andy's excited about it
I've played a bunch I think we can say
now and Mike's played as well and I came
look super cool I'm enjoying planet
Allah you guys excited about that
XCOM 2 I didn't play the last XCOM so I
still need to play that but I'm looking
forward to another strategy game coming
out in February what's that Fire Emblem
fates I saw you're gonna say fire watch
cuz that's coming at five februari 9 the
same day when's when's fire I'm were
coming in the 19th ok thank all right
yeah so if every 9th fire watches at
that'll be interesting the mighty number
nine is apparently coming out yeah we'll
see yeah it still has a list of like
seven or eight different consoles going
out on like Vita is on there and I think
367 I think we might be hot there so
we'll see you guys yeah and and then it
is a weird one so if every 9th is also
today unravel comes out yeah but if
you're an EA access you can play that on
the fourth ok this is your typical thing
I have five day but this is like a game
so yay access is a thing can play like
10 arrows exactly so you can complete
unravel basically it's 10 hours so you
can play it on the fourth if you want
it's one of three access games actually
to talk about here and when I know
you're excited about fabrics teen Street
Fighter fights coming yeah man can't
wait graphically looks a lot better
those like just the gameplay feel feels
a lot better and I think this time
around hopefully crossing my fingers I
don't say for Peter maybe um that I feel
like that more people will be able to
play this one at least it seems that way
it feels way on a second are you saying
hopefully for Peter because im a skrub
that's how I read it no no no I hope
that you feel the same way that we have
more people that want to play oh yeah I
mean that was just like I mean like I
love that we have people in the office
that love playing the game but like it
would be nice to have more people and I
feel like that's what they're trying to
push a little bit with this version
because there's a little bit of a little
bit more simplified mechanics but also
like there's high-level play which is
like finding that nice balance of you
know accessibility but you know high
level I'm looking forward to it I tried
to get into fighting games again on
street fighter 4 and i'm gonna try again
mr. price and we've also got a couple
days after that on febri 23rd Far Cry
primal is coming at at least on consoles
the pc versions are coming here for a
weekend I see isn't that is so crazy on
the corner like I kind of wouldn't be
surprised if like in two days time we
find out it's been pushed back a month
or something it better be in two days
cuz I got to start printing discs they
gotta do
so I feel like it's gonna come out
though yeah it's just so close it they
wouldn't be this far along are they
wouldn't have announced it so late that
close to the release date if they
weren't confident yeah that's a fair
point and also that same day if you're
not into Far Cry primal you can play
plants vs zombies garden warfare 2 which
is the second of the EA access games
which is coming out earlier you can play
it on februari 18th you so wish it's so
weird because the thing about unravel is
you can literally play the game EA
access isn't like it you can bias the
earlier Laguna you can just go play it
it's like I played enough need for speed
on EA access I got 10 hours and I came
that was enough I was like great yep
done same with battlefront done I
literally didn't buy bad front because
of the year would you would you have
purchased need for speed ok no I
actually would have wouldn't have bought
either of them that you right but I got
your subscription box right so that's
yeah that's how it pays off for them i
guess like it's a good way to sort of
like sweep up the people that yeah
probably wouldn't have invested 60 bucks
but in ten bucks I definitely bond
unraveled oh yeah yes no yeah that that
looks really interested that's a
strength does yeah but yeah if you want
you can get pvz2 on for every eighteenth
on EA access and rocket leagues coming
ad on xbox one sometime in February they
haven't CEO said when exactly so that's
TBA a but on the first of March finally
we can play David cages magnum opus
heavy rain on the PlayStation 4 it's
coming to next-gen consoles baby there
you go sure yeah French sand and
children and now on flex diction for all
right let's not talk about that yeah
March 8th tom clancy's the division is
coming at that's crazy that's like less
than two months away Emily couple months
ago we were saying where is the division
yeah it's knock knock knock we'll see
we'll see about that we can't we talk
more about that at all at the moment so
hopefully we will be able to soon and
march 11th hit man's coming out that was
a game that was originally gonna come at
December with that first package a
really weird release plan yeah where
it's like you're paying full price but
you're getting all the stuff but yeah
yeah I'll get it later yeah it's like I
yeah I've yet to see that work anyway
people were even frustrated with Mario
maker when it was giving youth things
yes like like hours later right so I do
you have weeks later for content who's a
bit crazy
at least revolt price game you know it's
the it's the sort of thing that I mean I
actually not a big hit man if in any way
or any kind of hit man fan that's the
sort of thing that just makes me feel
really comfortable not caring about that
oh really it's like personal level yeah
I'm the last game I guess well actually
last game is coming at that month is at
the end is us the new UFC from medical
McGregor shirt on the only champion on
the box netter razzy luster let's hope
there's no curse yeah that's true a
curse and that's that's the third of the
EA access ones but more importantly I
think for the wider gaming world March
28th is when a drift Chronos eval Corey
commish because it's the same day but
the oculus rift comes out Cronus is
awesome yeah I think once more people
get a chance to play that they'll
realize how how cool it is it's like the
wall it's one of the few games that I
think takes traditional game design and
ports it well to vr by tweaking a few
things it is sort of the atmosphere and
puzzles of Zelda with the the tone is
similar atmosphere but the tone and
gameplay of Dark Souls hmm uh it's it's
great it's real fun really liked it you
got me to fly ash gamescom yeah and I
was really taken back by how much I
enjoyed it actually it's good cool yeah
let's go I'm not alone oculus rift as
well if you pre-ordered you can get one
you'll be getting one on 28 hopefully I
know they they push back the dates for
some people and and then the last thing
I gave this its own section because
there's too many of them are not sure if
anyone gives a [ __ ] so if you don't care
about assassins creed chronicles you can
just stop watching this video right now
but if you do care and the last two
assassins creed chronicles games I guess
China came out last year physically came
out a while ago like if physically came
out may be back in september-october I
probably should research that been a
while anyway India assassin's creed
chronicles India coming at January 12
then assassin's creed chronicles russia
is coming at februari ninth and that's
also the same day that the trilogy which
will have China India and Russia all
together is coming in as well so if you
want to play some hot 2d Sasson screen
video game they got your back you'd be
soccer three games after you to play
okay that's that's all the games coming
in in q1 2016 if you have to pick a
favor right out of all of those what
would it be too
out of that probably street fighter 5
yeah with some hope that the vision is
kind of fun cuz ya something destiny
like but not destiny right now I'm
feeling real weird on the division I'm
feeling I can't get into it but I feel
like it's either gonna be it's either
gonna be another watchdog this
appointment or it's gonna be something
[ __ ] cool and I really can't tell
right now it's like I'm can't wait to
see more about that I'm probably more
excited about XCOM 2 than everything
else the witness is well I'm actually
super excited about and maybe Far Cry
primal what about yourself Fire Emblem
fates going on the dash street fighter 5
cool awesome let us know what you are
most excited about in the comment box
below what are you looking forward to in
q3 what do you think I'll slip on what
do you think will suck let us know in
the comments